[Applaus]
[Musik]
Spezialkräfte der Schweizer Armee üben
den Ernstfall
[Musik]
s
die Schweizer Armee wird sich wieder auf
die Verteidigung ausrichten
[Musik]
die Schweizer Armee soll wieder lernen
zu kämpfen so wie
[Musik]
Einstieg
zur besten
[Musik]
verteidigungsfreiheit die beste
kommt ein Traum in Trümmern
ich gebe zu dass ich nicht an den ewigen
Frieden in Europa geglaubt habe
und zieht sich nun mit einer Rückkehr
der Geschichte konfrontiert
Europa kann sich bei seiner Verteidigung
nicht einfach auf die USA verlassen
ich glaube viele Länder in Europa haben
höchstens für drei Tage vielleicht eine
Woche Munition
was viele nicht mehr für mögliche
hielten ist wieder Realität ein Krieg in
Europa
das ist nicht die Zukunft des Krieges
aber wir bekommen einen Eindruck von
künftigen Konflikten
was bedeutet diese neue Realität für die
Schweiz
wir müssen
[Musik]
Militärs und Forscher treffen sich nahe
Genf
Arche heißt die jährliche Veranstaltung
von arma Swiss und ETH Zürich beide
Welten sollen zusammenkommen zum
gegenseitigen Nutzen
[Musik]
was die Wissenschaft Entwickler und hier
präsentiere werde die Armee
ausschließlich zur Katastrophenhilfe
nutzen nie zum Kampf wird versichert
es braucht in der wenig Fantasie um sich
vorzustellen dass sich solche
Technologien auch als Waffen einsetzen
es wäre nicht schwierig das zum
missbrauchen habe ich den Eindruck
Armen die
ich weiß es nicht ich denke es wäre
nicht so einfach sie würden dieses Ding
schon von weitem kommen sehen und es
macht viel Lärm
es gäbe noch viel zu tun um daraus eine
effektive Waffe zu machen
das Beispiel Ukraine zeigt wie einfach
sich zum Beispiel Drohnen einsetzen
lassen sie bestimmen die Koordinaten von
Zielen oder sie fliegen kamikazeaktionen
[Musik]
Mitte August 2023
Armeechef süssli redet von Zäsur und
Zeitenwende und präsentiert den Medien
seine Zukunftsvision
die Nutzung neuer Technologien ist einer
von drei Kernpunkten
wir haben in der Schweiz eine gute
Ausgangslage als Technologiestandort mit
der Wirtschaft mit Start-ups mit den
Hochschulen wo das Einbeziehen um eben
die Chancen dieser Technologie zu nutzen
alle vorhandenen Chancen nutzen indem
das Wissen der Forscher gezielt
angezapft wird verrät uns der armee-chef
später
[Musik]
was will die nicht wissen
forces
zu der Universitäten
was für Technologie
wofür die Armee dieses Wissen einsetzt
wird sich zeigen
der 24 Februar 2022
seither sind viele Gewissheiten ins
Wanken geraten
am Rande Europas herrscht wieder Krieg
und in der Schweiz fragen sich viele was
hätte unser Militär einer solchen
Aggression entgegenzusetzen
kaum etwas sagte der Armeechef kurz nach
Russlands Angriff offen
[Musik]
mit unseren heutigen Mitteln wäre nach
ein paar Wochen Schluss
fakt ist
die Durchhaltefähigkeit der Armee ist
heute stark eingeschränkt
was heißt das konkret ja
2004 damals
Verteidigung nun also Kompetenz erhalten
am Anfang hat man erfolgreich
das bedeutet die Armee weiß zwar noch
wie Verteidigung geht aber sie kann sie
als Gesamtsystem kaum mehr gewährleisten
obwohl genau das laut Verfassung Ihr
Auftrag wäre
[Musik]
die Armee verteidigt das Land und seine
Bevölkerung
[Musik]
vom Land und da hat man eine letzte
Jahrzehnt irgendwie weniger drauf ist
und darum haben
[Musik]
ein Besuch in Brüssel zeigt nicht nur
die Schweiz sondern ganz Europa hat das
Kämpfen weitgehend verlernt
die EU ist bemüht um eine gemeinsame
außen sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik beraten durch einen
militärausschuss dem alle
generalstabchefs der eu-armeen angehören
Robert Brieger leitet das Gremium und
ist daher der ranghöchste eu-general
es hat nach dem Kalten Krieg
abrüstungstendenzen gegeben die also
sehr stark sowohl in Infrastruktur
Material und Personal eingegriffen haben
und das betrifft die
überwiegend meisten Streitkräfte in
Europa so dass diese Streitkräfte meiner
Einschätzung nach ein Jahrzehnt
benötigen werden um eine
Verteidigungsfähigkeit im Sinne
einer tatsächlichen Resilienz wieder
herzustellen
anders die Truppen der USA der letzten
verbliebenen Supermacht
sie leistet sich die stärkste Armee der
Welt
die USA blicken schon lange sorgenvoll
nach Europa dass sie stark ins
militarisiert hat
[Musik]
der Institute for the story of war einer
der weltweit führenden Militär
fängstucks
hierzu Lande wird der Europa als naiv
und geschichtsblind wahrgenommen
erzählt uns kimberlaken die Gründerin
und Leiterin des Instituts
Seiten des Friedens sind selten
Zeiten des Krieges sind normal die
Geschichte hat uns gezeigt dass Krieg
ein Teil von dem ist wie Menschen
Politik machen der
militärwissenschaftler Carl von
klausewitz drückte es so aus
Krieg ist die Fortsetzung der Politik
mit anderen Mitteln
Freiheit gebe es nicht umsonst sie müsse
verteidigt werden auch militärisch diese
Logik blieb in den USA stets präsent
[Musik]
das Weiße Haus setzte immer auf eine
Mischung aus Zuckerbrot und Peitsche
auch zu Zeiten von Präsident Obama
[Musik]
unter ihm stieg general David betrayers
hier rechts im Bild zum führenden
militär-direktor auf
Krieg verhindert man durch Abschreckung
diese Abschreckung hängt von zwei
Faktoren ab wie der Gegner unsere
Fähigkeiten und unseren Willen diese
einzusetzen einschätzt wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass es Glas klar ist dass wir
die Fähigkeiten haben und willens sind
diese einzusetzen um NATO-Länder zu
verteidigen
[Musik]
ein Rückfall in längst vergangen
geglaubte Zeiten
[Musik]
Spezialkräfte der Schweizer Armee
bereiten sich auf eine Übung vor das
Szenario eine bewaffnete Gruppe hat sich
in einem Haus im Wald verschanzt
[Musik]
Wachtmeister hat die Natur gemacht und
will bald ein geographie-studium
anfangen
er hat schon lange vor seiner Aushebung
intensiv trainiert um sich in Topform zu
bringen und es zu Elitetruppe zu
schaffen zu den Grenadieren
[Musik]
Spezialkräften will muss eine strenge
Selektion durchlaufen denn sie würden im
Falle eines Krieges an vorderster Front
stehen
[Musik]
Soldaten würden kämpfen das klingt
selbstverständlich ist es aber nicht
so hat eine Umfrage kürzlich ergeben
[Musik]
nur 54% der Rekruten sind bereit die
Schweiz im Falle eines Angriffs
persönlich zu verteidigen
ja die Zahl die aktiv verschieden aber
ich habe selber muss irgendwas in der
Situation ist ein wichtiger Aspekt wird
aussieht Unterstützung vor der
Bevölkerung an die gespürt dass
Bevölkerung
Verteidiger dass der Wille da ist dann
können
[Musik]
die Spezialkräfte bereiten sich auf
einen Ernstfall vor von dem alle hoffen
dass er nie eintritt
[Musik]
würde die Schweiz angegriffen wäre nicht
nur der fehlende kampfeswelle von großen
Teilen der Truppe ein Problem die Armee
hätte auch viel zu wenig Leute
ein Lösungsansatz auf dem Weg zur
Besserung könnte sein künftig nicht nur
die Männer sondern auch die Frauen in
die Pflicht zu nehmen
[Musik]
die obligatorische
Berechtigung
aber wir reden viele andere Orte die
Gleichberechtigung
der Exodus der Männer hält derweil an
[Musik]
jedes Jahr verlassen etwa 11.000
militärdienstpflichtige die Armee
vorzeitig und 60 Prozent wechseln in den
Zivildienst und rund 30% werden aus
medizinischen Gründen entlassen
[Musik]
Rückblende ins Jahr 2009
die Bereitschaft einen Zivildienst zu
leisten der deutlich länger dauert als
der Militärdienst gilt ab jetzt als
ausreichender Nachweis für einen
Gewissenskonflikt
[Musik]
ein Gesuch reicht und man ist weg
und das ist meine Augen
die Schweiz hat zwar weiter eine
Wehrpflicht aber seit 2009 faktisch eine
freiwillige Armee
viel viel viel
und die Weiterentwicklung
Korrekturen bleiben aus der Trend hielt
an gut 6000 Männer gehen ja für Jahr in
den Zivildienst
für mich ist das in erster Linie
dass der Armee attraktiv ist dass junge
Menschen sehen wollen
das bringt mir ein bisschen erstens kann
ich etwas bringen versichert vom Land
zweitens aber hat die Dienstleistung
und wenn ich das besser klingt und euch
Verbesserung nicht nur
kommunikative Option für mich ist der
Station selber besser zu werden bevor
das noch mal andere Ort probiert
[Musik]
ein Propaganda Film der Schweizer Armee
aus den 1960er Jahren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
damals problemlos alimentiert mit den
Söhnen der Aktivdienst Generation
der Zweite Weltkrieg war noch Teil des
kollektiven Gedächtnisses
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie Adolf Hitler 1939 Europas brüchigen
Frieden brach
[Applaus]
wie die Schweizer Soldaten ohne Flieger
Abwehr in den Aktivdienst einrücken
die Schweiz war unvorbereitet ihre
Führung mutlos und resigniert
[Musik]
bis er kam und dem Volk den Glauben an
die eigenen Stärken zurückgab general
origin
[Applaus]
in diesem Falle nicht nur halten sondern
sich mit aller Kraft fragen
zerstören sein Leben so teuer wie
möglich verkauft
rund 500 Offiziere von Majoran aufwärts
brachen im Juli 1940 auf Richtung
rüdling
das Rütli als Wahrzeichen einer
wehrhaften Schweiz unterstrich general
die sonst widerstandsrede
[Musik]
general guisans Plan war toll kühl er
propagierte den Rückzug der Truppen ins
rewi tief hinein in die Schweizer Berge
große Teile des Landes hätte man
geopfert
[Musik]
alte Frauen und Kinder sie alle hätte
die Armee zurückgelassen dem Feind
praktisch schutzlos ausgeliefert
[Musik]
eine traumatische Erfahrung die sich
keinesfalls wiederholen sollte sagt
Georg Heßler Sicherheitsexperte der
Neuen Zürcher Zeitung und Oberst in der
Armee
unbedingt
es folgt der Kalte Krieg
die Gefahr eines Atomkrieges ist nun um
die präsent
bewusst gesehen dass Armee oder das Land
umfassen soll können verteidigen dass
das enorm Dürer
quasi mit den Atombomben
der Bundesrat ist 1958 überzeugt dass
der Armee die wirksamsten Waffen gegeben
werden müssen dazu gehören die
Atomwaffen
[Musik]
die Armee 61 bekommt schließlich keine
Atombombe
dafür 800.000 Männer unter Waffen und
über 10 Milliarden Franken Jahresbudget
TE
hat keine Armee sie ist eine Armee also
die Armee die Gesellschaft oder
das hält bis weit in die 1980er Jahre an
ich bin first Militär ich bin
förderverteidigung und wenn man einmal
so eine Kläger haltet das geht so
einfach nicht
Bilder aus Dübendorf aus dem Jahr 1986
[Musik]
der Armee kommt der Wahl der Feind
abhanden denn der Kalte Krieg beginnt zu
tauen
und ganz neue grundsätzliche Fragen
werden möglich
[Applaus]
ST
stark prägt
1989 die Berliner Mauer fällt
[Musik]
immer mehr Menschen fragen sich wozu
braucht es jetzt noch Militär
in der Schweiz kommt eine Initiative zur
Abschaffung der Armee zur Abstimmung
die Gruppe für eine Schweiz ohne Armee
Kurz xora findet die Schweiz sollte
besser in die aktive Friedensförderung
investieren
frisst sehr viel Geld über 10 Milliarden
alljährlich aber genau mit dem Geld kann
man dazu
unwahrscheinlicher wird andere
Strukturen nach dem Mauerfall wird
abgestimmt
bei der armeeabschaffung Initiative
36,6% ja stehen
63,4 Prozent nein gegenüber Fazit
Schweiz
die heilige Kuh nicht geschlachtet
sondern mit der heilige Schiene
weggenommen
gut 30 Jahre später herrscht Krieg in
der Ukraine das hat Auswirkungen auf die
Einstellung der Schweizer Bevölkerung
[Musik]
78% erachten die Armee heute als
notwendig 12% möchten die Armee
abschaffen
welche Schlüssel sollen Europas Armeen
aus den Bildern die uns täglich aus der
Ukraine erreichen nun ziehen
zuerst und vor allem muss in die
Bereitschaft investiert werden
sicherstellen dass die bestehenden
Waffensysteme seines Panzerschiffe
Flugzeuge was auch immer einsatzfähig
sind und das jene die dieses Systeme
bedienen trainiert und bereit sind
dann unbedingt die Munitionsbestände
auffüllen und schließlich braucht es
eine Transformation weg von wenigen
großen und unbeweglichen Plattformen hin
zu vielen kleinen beweglichen
diese werden zunehmend unbemannt sein am
Boden in der Luft im Wasser und im
Cyberspace
[Musik]
die Digitalisierung der Schweizer
Streitkräfte soll in den kommenden
Jahren adaptiv sozusagen in rollender
Planung vorangetrieben werden
milliarden sollen in neue Technologien
fließen denn sie würden die
Kriegsführung revolutionieren ist die
Armee überzeugt
[Musik]
die neue Mittel also Effizienz vor allem
das Kraftfahrzeug
Satelliten Aufklärung
das Parlament wird sich im kommenden
Jahr mit süßlich Vision befassen nichts
davon ist bisher abgesegnet auch die
Kosten nicht
der Aufwuchs für diese Armee der
niedererlang der Verteidigungsfähigkeit
wird ungefähr insgesamt bis zu 50
Milliarden Schweizer Franken kosten
Mitte August 2023 die Armee präsentiert
sich der Bevölkerung an einer
Ausstellung
ich finde sie sehr professionell sehr
innovativ
man dürfen die Bedeutung dieser neuen
Technologien auch nicht überschätzen
warnt derweil die Expertin aus den USA
[Musik]
wenn wir anders Aufkommen der Luftwaffen
zurückdenken als strategisches
bombardieren möglich wurde damals hörte
man Armeen werde es bald nicht mehr
brauchen
es gab also schon immer die Hoffnung
dass ein technologischer Fortschritt den
Krieg so verändern wird dass man ihn
antiseptisch führen kann sauber aus
weiter Distanz mit geringen Kosten
Technologie verändert den Krieg
natürlich aber er wird weiterhin von
bewaffneten Menschen gekämpft
willkommen zur Befehlsausgabe für die
Mission 418 ramadur im hoch
für die Spezialkräfte wird es ernst
ich komme zu den Aufträgen
für Reto schminkt
nimmt und hält auf Befehl GARANTA das
Zielobjekt Emerald und Helium
heute Nacht müssen sie ausrücken und
eine bewaffnete Gruppe gespielt von
Kameraden überwältigen diese haben sich
in einer Hütte im Wald verschanzt
sie wissen es
gut
[Musik]
Wachtmeister Nils Dörr und seine
Kameraden decken sich mit Material ein
mit Munition blind und Handgranaten
natürlich alle nicht scharf damit sich
niemand verletzt
[Musik]
en
wie schwierig ist das alles wissen sie
dass
um die 5 kg
15 Kilo ja
halb vier Kilo also
[Musik]
Anfang 2010 kurz nach seinem Amtsantritt
am Kader Tag mit Chef Beamten und
Offizieren wird gute Stimmung verbreitet
auch wenn alle wissen dass die Armee in
einem langen tapen Zustand ist
warm
es muss uns um den letzten Jahren
gelingen die notwendigen Mittel
aufzutreiben die Leute zu motivieren
sie ihre
tatortsoldaten und dann sind wir auf
gutem Weg zur besten Armee der Welt
[Musik]
die Armee musste in den vergangenen 30
Jahren sparen wo sie konnte etwa in dem
atomschutzunterstände außer Betrieb
genommen wurden
[Musik]
das Militär schien nur zu kosten aber
kaum noch eine Nutzen zu haben
was ich entsorgen ließ wurde darum
entsorgt
[Musik]
angefangen hat der Niedergang der
Schweizer Armee nach dem Kalten Krieg
damals wird aus der Armee 61 die Armee
die Mannstärke wird deutlich reduziert
von 600.000 auf 400.000 Material
infrastruktur-
der damalige russische Präsident scheint
kaum noch jemandem gefährlich werden zu
können
[Musik]
die Spannungen von einst haben sich in
Wohlgefallen aufgelöst
[Musik]
auf Kasper Villiger folgt 1995 Adolf
oggi als Verteidigungsminister og
richtet die Armee in den folgenden
Jahren völlig neu aus die neue Armee 21
der aktive truppenbestand wird noch mal
drastisch reduziert von 360.000 auf
120.000 und die Armee bekommt einen
neuen Fokus weg von der Verteidigung
schützen und helfenischen
die Soldaten stampfen nun Schneepisten
am Lauberhornrennen
sie kommen am World Economic Forum in
Davos zum Einsatz
[Musik]
und drei
und sie fördern den Frieden in Missionen
im Ausland Sicherheit durch Kooperation
heißt fortan das Motto
die Logik dahinter geben um nötigenfalls
auch nehmen zu können
[Musik]
für das sie von der Sicherheit vor dem
Auto hat profitieren der Gedanke
[Musik]
ein Verteidigungsbündnis von 31
europäischen und nordamerikanischen
Staaten
an ihrem 70 Geburtstag war sie noch
heillos zerstritten
US-Präsident Donald Trump drohte damit
austritt
erst der Krieg in der Ukraine brachte
die Wende
Putin wollte Russland wieder groß machen
indem er seine Nachbarn überfiel was er
wirklich getan hat er hat die NATO
wieder groß gemacht putin ist das größte
Geschenk für die NATO seit dem Ende des
Kalten Krieges
heute ist die NATO sogar ein und stark
wie lange nicht mehr
und für die neutrale Schweiz stellt sich
die Frage ob sie künftig enger
kooperieren soll mit dem
Verteidigungsbündnis
eine aktuelle Umfrage der ETH Zürich
zeigt
55% unterstützen eine NATO Annäherung
31% sind für eine NATO-Beitritt
würde die Schweiz der NATO beitreten
müsste sie ihre Neutralität aufgeben
weiterhin undenkbar
91% wollen die Beibehaltung der
Neutralität
und Welle ich nicht in fremde
militärische Konflikt da übrigens bzw
möglich
wenn wir ihn soweit wir im Schnitt in
fremde militärische Konflikte wir können
aber müssen klar festhalten dass wir im
Ernstfall nicht warten unterstützen die
Verteidigungsministerin möchte sich also
der NATO annähern aber neutral bleiben
würde die Schweiz angegriffen wohl mit
der NATO kooperieren aber vorher nicht
beitreten und künftig jährlich ein
Prozent des BIP in die Armee investieren
während die naturländer das Doppelte
anstreben
die Schweiz profitiert von
sicherheitsschirmen der NATO
sie genießt die Vorteile eines
friedlichen und blühenden Europas
ohne sich genügend an den Kosten zu
beteiligen
es wird immer gewisse Länder geben die
von den bestehenden Umständen
profitieren offen gesagt es wäre toll
wenn die Schweiz der NATO beitreten
würde
beispielsweise in der Luft leistet die
Schweiz in Kooperation mit dem
umliegenden Ausland einen wichtigen
Beitrag sagt die Armee mit dem
luftpolizeidienst
Mario Thöni Militärpilot in Bayern
stationiert
er und seine Kollegen stellen sicher
dass die Schweizer Luftwaffe stets
einsatzbereit ist
Messi da drüben
[Musik]
diese Alarm ist nicht echt sondern zu
Übungszwecken
[Musik]
Jenny und seine Kollegen fliegen immer
wieder sogenannte hot missions eine Art
blaulichteinsätze bei der Verletzung des
Schweizer Luftraumes oder wenn die
luftverkehrsregeln grob missachtet
werden
[Musik]
die FA 18 die hier zum Einsatz kommen
wurden in der 1990er Jahren geschafft
[Musik]
ein zentrales Kriterium bei der Wahl des
Flugzeugs sei die Möglichkeit gewesen
problemlos mit dem Ausland kooperieren
zu können die sogenannte
Interoperabilität
einerseits beim luftpolizeidienst aber
auch im Falle eines Konfliktes sagt er
Sicherheitsexperte der NZZ
die RV 18 das wäre natürlich ein
Möglichkeiten
Sicherheitssituation sofort können es
kooperieren miteinander
Revolution günstigsten
und den Druck ist positiv aber ich habe
eine profitieren
Luftpolizei die entstehen jetzt schon
zusammen schaffen mit der Nachbarländer
wir haben die Sicherheit
ohne dass er mit Deutschland
und das funktioniert sehr gut
damit das so bleibt beschafft die
Schweiz nun den F35 aus den USA
im Ernstfall soll dieses Kampfflugzeug
auch Ziele im Ausland ausschalten können
allein oder im Verbund mit der NATO
ein neues Szenario das sich eher
interdiction nennt und bis vor kurzem
noch geheim war heute werden diese
offensivstrategien offen ausgesprochen
dass ihre Ziele reicht das ist neu sich
verteidigen mit offensiven Aktionen im
Ausland also ich würde jetzt mit Omas
irgendetwas
der Krieg in der Ukraine hat offenbar
alles verändert
auch in Finnland
[Musik]
general Timo der finnische armee-chef
besucht seine Truppe
sie hätten immer eine starke
Verteidigungsarmee gehabt sagt er
jetzt da das Nachbarland im Krieg ist
wollte sich Finnland nicht mehr nur auf
die eigenen Soldaten verlassen
eine überwältigende Mehrheit sprach sich
für eine NATO-Beitritt aus
super
die Unterstützung für einen
NATO-Beitritt war vor der russischen
Aggression im Februar 2022 unter 30
Prozent
zehn Tage nach der Invasion lag sie bei
70% und stieg weiter
würden sie anderen Ländern auch eine
größere Kooperation empfehlen
diese Diskussion sollte jedes Land
intern führen
die finnische Armee müsste ihr Land
künftig nicht mehr allein verteidigen
sondern in einer großen Allianz
mit dem NATO-Beitritt haben sich die
Finnen aber auch dazu verpflichtet ihre
Verteidigungsausgaben massiv zu erhöhen
der Wunschzettel des Armeechefs ist
bereits lang
[Applaus]
eine zeitgemäße Verteidigung braucht
eine Kombination
high-end-technologien und große Reserven
so können wir zu Beginn einer Krise
schnell agieren aber auch lange
durchhalten
was wir alle in Europa jetzt dringend
tun müssen unsere Munitionslager
auffüllen
das machen wir auch
Jahrzehnten der Abrüstung wird wieder
auf breiter Front aufgerüstet
und die Armeen Europas suchen den
Schulterschluss
das Schweizer Militär formuliert es so
ein Alleingang ist keine
erfolgversprechende Option
in Europa das nächste Beispiel ist
Israel aber inneren
Israel ein Land umzingelt von Feinden
und darum quasi zum Alleingang verdammt
Lisa Alleingang ist teuer
Israel investiert sechs Prozent seines
BIP in die Verteidigung also gut
sechsmal mehr als die Schweiz
Männer müssen fast drei Jahre
durchgehend ins Militär Frauen 2
eine eigene hightech-rüstungsindustrie
versorgt die Truppe laufend mit dem
neuesten equipment
eine Armee für einen Alleingang fit zu
machen sei sehr komplex sagt general
Amos der ehemalige Luftwaffenchef
das ist der Auto die Kunst besteht darin
alle Elemente des Krieges miteinander zu
kombinieren den Boden die Luft das
Wasser den Cyber und den
Informationsraum
der Plattform
natürlich brauchen Sie Präzisionswaffen
aber diese sind wertlos wenn Sie nicht
über ausgezeichnete Geheimdienste
verfügen die müssen den Präzisionswaffen
die genauen Ziele liefern
es braucht einen fähigen
Oberbefehlshaber professionelle
Kaderleute und eine funktionierende
Befehlskette zu dem viel Training es
dauert Jahre so eine Armee aufzubauen
im Juni 1967 zeigt Israel der Welt wozu
eine solche Armee im Stande ist
in nur sechs Tagen setzt sich Israel
gegen Ägypten Jordanien und Syrien durch
der sogenannte sechs Tage Krieg eine
blutige Machtdemonstration
kleine Länder müssen stark sein sonst
werden sie attackiert oder annektiert
wenn ihr einen langen Frieden wollt
bereitet euch auf den Krieg vor dann
überlegte sich euer feind zweimal
die brutalen Logiken der Abschreckung
sie kehren nun auch nach Europa zurück
darüber hätten wir gerne mit dem
russischen Botschafter in Bern
gesprochen und über die Frage ob sich
die Schweiz vor Russland fürchten muss
er sagt aus Zeitgründen ab der
Nachrichtendienst des Bundes stellt
indes fest ein bewaffneter Angriff
Russlands auf die Schweiz bleibt äußerst
unwahrscheinlich
ich will mich nicht auf
irgendein Region fokussiere hier wir
müssen reden
2001 kam die Gefahr aus der Luft seither
galt Terror als die konkreteste Gefahr
für die Schweiz
[Musik]
ich glaube Thema
die Bedrohung durch Terror ist
hochgeblieben in Europa Armeen spielten
in diesem Kontext allerdings immer nur
eine Nebenrolle die Polizei stand im
Fokus
etwa in Frankreich bewachten Soldaten
höchstens Infrastrukturen oder
patroullierten
[Musik]
Mann der mitten im ausreichend dann hat
er mehr unterstützen und das wird sie
auch in Zukunft
wir kehren noch einmal zurück nach
Israel
zu Jammers einer undercover
Spezialeinheit der Polizei
Profis die den Kampf gegen den Terror
täglich üben
diese Männer sind Polizisten und
bekommen ihre Informationen für Zugriffe
vom Geheimdienst
[Applaus]
wer Terror bekämpfen will muss also hier
investieren in Spezialeinheiten der
Polizei und in den Geheimdienst
die Gegner sind in Israel klar im
Gegensatz zur Schweiz wo es zwar
generell unsicherer geworden sein soll
ansonsten aber alles sehr die Fuß bleibt
für Zukunft
Europa im ganz Europa Potenzial
[Musik]
morgens um vier Uhr der Höhepunkt der
Übung der Spezialkräfte der Schweizer
Armee der Zugriff
[Musik]
sie üben eine Terrorzelle auszuheben die
sich verschanzt hat eine Aufgabe die das
Militär wohl auch künftig getrost der
Polizei überlassen kann
[Musik]
auf welche Szenarien sollen diese
Soldaten nun sinnvollerweise vorbereitet
werden
diese Frage stellt sich für die ganze
Armee die politische Debatte darüber hat
gerade erst begonnen
[Musik]
ich bin sehr froh dass Thema Sicherheit
jetzt wieder so stark diskutiert wird
wichtig dass man sich bewusst ist in der
Politik und in der Bevölkerung
[Musik]
wie teuer darf die Armee künftig sein
woher kommen die Leute um all die leeren
Ränge zu füllen und sollen die Soldaten
die Schweiz allein verteidigen können
oder in internationaler Kooperation
wohin soll es gehen mit der Schweizer
Armee der Zukunft
darüber wird nun die Politik entscheiden
müssen
[Musik]